first a breakfast to really set you up
for the day
easy homemade spicy baked beans with
deliciously light potato cakes
[Music]
the first big thing that i remember as a
kid was
bacon and beans so this is like a little
rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta ernie come on
disappear go and chase some mice now
panel get nice and hot
i'm gonna turn these beans into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly season that it's cured so it
doesn't need
that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how the individual tastes
of baked beans they're
somewhat bland so i always like to make
them a little bit more
spicy so a nice
finely chopped chili with
the seeds chili in
now a little bit of garlic
crushed phenomenal
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards slice across
then cut down to simply dice
bacon onion chilli garlic that flavour
all contained in that little pan once
you've sweated the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there the brown
sugar will start to caramelize
darken and enrich it as well at the same
time
that looks beautiful now
a couple of tablespoons of cider vinegar
delays the pan
it's got that really nice powerful kick
to it now spice that up
with one of my favorite seasonings
worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your passata puree tomatoes
turn that down some of the sauce to
reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harrico beans
you can buy haircut beans dried or
canned they are packed with protein
and have a lovely soft texture turn down
the heat
and let the beans absorb all that
beautiful
spicy tomato sauce and just let that
simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes
and are so easy to make
i'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour
and butter to the mash that gives it
that nice sort of
cakey texture and it goes from this
leftover ball potato
to this nice light
flowery potato heaven
take a nice spoon of potato lightly
flour your board we're gonna fry these
crisp on the outside and
just nice and fluffy in the center
now get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil into the
pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
it's always sort of nut brown gently
turn them over love that nice
light crisp they look beautiful
now take them out
oh potato cake in the middle
and a nice beautiful spoon
of beans growing up with beans on toast
as a
treat still to this day after all those
years
has not changed my love or attitude for
beans
especially cooked like that
my smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes
comfort and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
when i was growing up food in britain
was somewhat different to what it is now
no one had heard of organic you couldn't
even buy avocados
in the shops where i lived paris
kitchens might have been cooking
nouvelle cuisine but it certainly hadn't
made any inroads
around our way malta my lunch when i was
growing up was very plain
pretty trashy but i still love it now
and again fish fingers with a delicious
chip butty
secret of a good chip butty
is in the potato now these are
desiree potatoes one of my first ever
jobs
was working in a chip shop i used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which will send the potato
peeler
all day long today i'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a twist simply
peel
slice and blanch for three to four
minutes
drain season and cover well
with papika spread evenly over an oiled
baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that next up easy fish fingers
this is pollock a really nice firm
delicious
fish got the fish in finger size batons
of fish
put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them
you can do that literally 20 minutes 30
minutes before
you start cooking the fish it firms the
fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan
now for the coating start by thoroughly
coating the fish
in seasoned flour and then just roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then
it stops those corners almost burning in
the pan
in to your egg wash and really coat them
wonderful and then this is dill
goes brilliantly well with a fish and
run the dill
through my breadcrumbs that makes it
more aromatic
lay them onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful
once the fish fingers are thoroughly
coated they're ready to pan fry
and they'll need around three minutes on
each side
i want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first
and then we'll flip them over and finish
them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan and a
nice
little knob of butter that'll work
wonders with the breadcrumbs and the
dill
nice and carefully take them out
they look and smell incredible stay nice
and crispy
now to assemble my chip butty starting
with buttered thick crusty bread
your slice of bread mop up
that amazing flavor
on slice in half
never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with the ship butty there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that i've never
forgotten the joy i've come for food
but my god that makes me feel like a
nine year old
excuse me for a moment we want to stuff
my face
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip buddy
so simple to make but trust me it tastes
amazing
a dish becomes a classic because it's
delicious and somehow strikes are called
with us
it just works sometimes these dishes can
become tired
but a clever twist helps make them fresh
again
you can't get more classic than a
centuries-old midday meal of bread
cheese and beer reinvented and marketed
by pubs as a plan was launched in the
60s
i'm now giving it my 21st century take
like plummets with the most amazing but
super simple beer baked bread
hearty and full of flavor for a really
quick and easy bread dough
sieve a mix of wholemeal and
self-raising white flour with a good
pinch of salt
salt is really important the bread it's
the first thing i do once i've cracked
it and smelt
you want to smell that salt baked
throughout
beer in about 250 mils of beer
[Music]
the reason why this recipe works so well
is it the beer it's got that yeast
so naturally it's gonna work beautifully
give that a really good mix
i'm looking for the mixture to be quite
wet if the dough
becomes too firm then it's going to cook
dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
whisk that is perfect
beautiful this mix will work really well
as one large loaf but
i want to make my plan ones a little bit
more special
small tins give it that kind of intimacy
and i quite like
having my own little loaf give the molds
a really nice
lining with butter make sure you butter
the top
now tablespoon of flour dust inside the
mold
that will stop your mixture sticking
tap out any excess three quarters fill
your little molds
we're going to allow it to sort of rise
just so it comes above
the mold and forms this really nice
miniature loaf
onto the tray centimeter apart into the
oven
25 to 30 minutes at 180.
something quite nice about the smell of
home baked bread in the kitchen
delicious
no plan was it's complete without
pickled onions
red onion is a lot sweeter less harsh
than a white onion the early days of
plum ones you've got those ghastly sharp
pickled onions that make you almost cry
when you're crunching them i'm gonna
lightly pickle
my red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings
a little touch of salt a little sprinkle
of sugar
and then a couple of cloves in there
that gives it a really nice sort of
perfume
and sort of makes the pickling slightly
more mellow
red wine vinegar now if you haven't got
red wine vinegar white wine vinegar it's
just as good but red
matches the red onion so it goes hand in
glove a couple of tablespoons
of vinegar just give that a really good
mix to speed up the pickling process
use a weight to put pressure on the
onions
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
work their magic
and it comes out with a really nice
light fragrant pickle
for my 21st century ploughmans i'm
creating an all-in-one salad and
bringing the traditional elements
together with a punchy dressing
a tablespoon of english mustard a
tablespoon of honey
a touch of salt and pepper and finish
off with white wine vinegar and olive
oil
[Music]
now generally it's sort of three parts
oil to one part vinegar
that's the sort of general base
[Music]
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with a plan ones but this is a really
nice sort of modern
approach to ploughmans for my plan
salad i'm using a mixture of robust and
crunchy romaine lettuce
and punchy watercress if i was making a
watercress soup i'd use the stalks
but the stalks are a little bit bitter
so i just grabbed them like that pinch
them and then twist
very peppery very hot but so juicy
watercress in your celery chop it
nice and finely it's the one thing that
everybody leaves is that stick of celery
so
scatter it amongst the salad
a bit of oomph and color from some
sliced radishes and sweetness from a
thinly sliced apple
whilst you're busy throwing your plum
and salad together do not forget
about your beer bread before it comes
out i'm gonna glaze the top with a
little touch of milk
that'll put a really nice finish to the
bread back in for the last five minutes
now for the magic in the plan ones
generally you'll see it as a ham or
cheddar
or stilton flourman's it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate plowmans i'm adding
all three
brilliant cheddar peel some nice shards
of that
delicious creamy cheddar just get them
dancing on top
the dressing drizzle ran in circles
and then finally our delicious
lightly pickled onions give them a good
squeeze
and look just dot the onions around
bread it's ready
it's got that nice yeasty smell
warm crusty and delicious
there you go that is my classic modern
version
of a traditional stunning player lens
wow my delicious all-in-one plan one
salad
with individual beer bread loaves
updated for the 21st century
you